hey was klappt jetzt willkommen beim
neuen video
herzlich willkommen beim neuen video und
wir haben heute einen ganz bestimmten
gast den hier alle sehr mit hoffe ich
wenn ich dann so schlimm
auf jeden fall ist das meine freundin
leute und wir haben uns heute was
heftiges überlegt also das ist also ein
video konzept wodurch meinen kanal
damals wirklich durch die decke gegangen
ist auf jeden fall sind davon noch drei
formate auf dem channel online das habe
ich aber das war nicht meine freunde des
wald einfach irgendein mädchen mädchen
genau aber jetzt habe ich ja weg ich
eine freundin ich habe mir eine
wunderhübsche freundin geangelt also
wenn ihr das format nicht kennt es geht
einfach darum ihr habt mir auf instagram
geschrieben irgendwelche dinge die man
zu seiner freundin auf keinen fall sagen
sollte irgendwas lustiges ich habe ja
noch selber ein bisschen was ausgedacht
und dass du kannst es auch noch nicht
also nicht so gut dass sie jetzt gleich
wenn ich die anderen kopf und du darfst
sondern abwägen ob das schlimm ist oder
nicht um das ganze natürlich nicht so
langweilig zu gestalten habe ich mir
damals was richtig krank überlegt und
zwar immer wenn man etwas schlimm findet
darfst du mir eine klasse damen
allerdings viele gesagt es ist ja dumm
wenn man dann darf man ja immer schlagen
und deswegen habe ich mir für heute
überlegt wir machen das so du darfst
dich von zehn dingen die ich niemals zu
dir sagen solche drei mal schlagen und
die sache die du am schlimmsten findest
da habe ich wirklich ganz tief in die
trickkiste gegriffen und hab mir eine
benjamin grimm schimpfte zugelegt diesen
so gehören die einfach viel besser essen
ja ich erst danach hab heute kennt ihr
diese benjamin blümchen torten die waren
auf jedem kindergeburtstag der renner
also leute ihr könnt euch wahrscheinlich
schon vorstellen die sache die sie am
schlimmsten schulter darf wieder diese
torte ins gesicht schauen
hallo hört dass hier noch drin ja aber
ich habe ihn doch ich freue mich schon
wenn ich nehme mir so auseinander diese
torte wenn ihm ein gesicht ist ja leute
jetzt wollen gar nicht dran glauben und
fangen sofort waren ich würde sagen weil
15.000 leicht selbst irgendwann mal eine
zweite folge wenn ich wieder lust auf ok
matthias kurtz am 1
mein bizeps ein bisschen weiter
ok ok schon fällt also merkt das gut von
zehn mal dass nur drei mal zuschlagen
noch mal fest welcher schlager so leicht
zu vielleicht ich weiß nicht ob du es
kann und leute das ist alles nur spaß
ist meine ich nicht ernst was ich sage
jetzt genug unterhaltung und das nur
spaß und sie wird mich sonst auch
niemals schlagen
außer manchmal vielleicht wir fangen
erst waren mit was nicht ganz so schlimm
und zwar passt warum sind wir damals bei
unserem ersten date nicht einfach ins
schwimmbad gegangen ich meinen hätte ich
dich wenigstens schon mal ungeschminkt
sehen können ist nicht schlimm
oder wenn sie mich jetzt ungemütlich
deswegen ja doch deswegen haben manche
sachen die mir geschrieben habt die sind
so irgendwie halt so weil die so krass
schlecht sind jetzt ich fand es witzig
sind schon wieder lustig so einfach so
hast du mal wieder bei mcdonald manchmal
mir also ein richtig schönes wochenende
zusammen verbringen dann bis montag
naja bewahre die reine drei schläge auf
das wird noch schlimmer also meine
favoriten kommers am schluss okay die
nächste sache kommt von alex wiking
danke für die seite finde ich super
also du hast voll und ganz recht und
zwar hab dich lieb
das weiß einer von aber nicht naja egal
die torte nehme ich in kauf die wird
geile der macht so ach komm her du hast
den perfekten körper nicht so dünn wie
diese ganzen models weil jedes mädchen
will ja unbedingt so aussehen wie diese
ganzen models auch wenn ich es nicht
verstehe ich habe das jetzt nur mit
reingenommen war ja wirklich sehr viele
mädchen immer aussehen wollen wie diese
models auf instagram instagram wie diese
ganzen morgens auf instagram die da
irgendwas mit photoshop bearbeitet haben
wobei ich immer nur denken kann leute
passt mal auf das ist gar nicht so schön
nur weil ihr euch irgendwas vorleben
müsst ihr das ja nicht nach leben also
ich stehe voll auf dich
volk lieber mir auf instagram dann müsst
ihr nicht irgendwie anders an sowas
denken und was sehen als doch so das
nächste ich auch schon mal drin in
irgendeinem video davon und zwei mädchen
sind wie busse wenn du 1 verpasst nimmst
du einfach den nächsten verstehst du
also dann fährt ein bus weg und wollen
wir nicht und so auch wenn ein mädchen
weg ist einfach das nächste nein
schreibt noch ein
weißt du was ich ihr schon immer mal
sagen wollte du bist unbezahlbar weil es
gibt halt eben keine halben fans höchst
von richtig gut
warum nicht schwarz-weiße was mit der
figur kannst du wirklich alles tragen
doch am besten gleich mal den müll raus
also das war nicht immer das fand ich
wirklich richtig kreativ und lustig
wird's nicht schlimm
naja gut es heißt doch immer das runde
muss ins eckige
ab ins bett mit dir weiß warum
ja nicht schlimm da hatte wie viele
fragen langen beine kommen das war schon
okay leute und jetzt kommen wir zu
meinen absoluten favoriten so leute
fragt mich mal ob ich fremd gehen
das musste zu einer machen so fremd wie
so freue mich dass nur alle
91 ich liebe die benjamin blümchen total
schatzministers alles selber machen kann
es ja schon mal anfangen ich mein herz
gleichfalls orgel wahlleute na ja ich
würde sagen das war's mit dem video ich
hoffe natürlich dass hat es gefallen und
vertreibt europaweit über dinge die man
niemals schüler freunde laden die
kommentare und dann gucke ich mir das
mal an und versuchten nur zwei gefolge
als 15.000 leicht hab ich ja gesagt
also wenn sie gefallen lassen doch nach
oben einfach mal da und merke ja gar
nicht an
und genau gucken finster richtigen leute
ist für hauptrollen in kurven die kamera
aber